The answer I'm looking for here is 10.
Certainly if we're just going to rearrange these elements,
the only way that these three elements can satisfy the heap property is if we put the 10 at the top
and we can actually leave the 17 where it is and the heap property will still be maintained at this node.
We'd swap the 10 and the 41 and now, this subtree may no longer have the heap property,
but we can make a new picture that looks a little something like this
where we have two smaller trees and these have to satisfy the heap property
because the whole subtree that we had here used to satisfy it
until we got that nice 10 out of the way and put in a nasty 41,
but notice now we're in the same situation we were in a moment ago, but on a smaller scale.
We have two subtrees that satisfy the heap property and a root that doesn't.
We can now repeat this process pushing these nasty values
down and down and deeper and deeper into the tree until they hit the bottom at a leaf
at which point, it doesn't matter how bit they are, the leaves can be very, very large.